[Musica]
io faccio l'autore televisivo e sono
molto felice stasera di darvi una
notizia facciamo tutti lo stesso
mestiere
siamo tutti autori noi siamo da qualche
anno dieci anni per la precisione che
grazie a quel aggeggio che portiamo in
tasca allo smartphone
noi siamo tutti autori ora cos'è
l'autore no l'autore è colui o colei che
ha un'idea che prima non esisteva la
realizza e poi la diffonde e questa idea
può essere un racconto una battuta una
foto una ricetta di cucina
un'equazione matematica qualcosa che
prima non esiste e poi è di tutti dieci
anni dicevo perché nel 2008
non so per quale motivo ma in italia c'è
il boom di facebook il social facebook
più famoso al mondo già esisteva da
qualche anno ma nel 2008 esplode ci
scriviamo tutti in massa le compreso io
ho avuto da poco la prima figlia quindi
tra in quel momento aureo splendido che
va tra una pappa e un pianto
c'è un oretta no di solito di pace io
tendo accendo il computer che mi iscrivo
a facebook e facebook sa una cosa strana
introduce una cosa strana in quel mondo
che è internet e il web una cosa in
qualche modo non era mai avvenuta
soprattutto per socializzare ti chiede
nome e cognome una foto magari il numero
di telefono una carta d'identità per
dimostrare che sei quello lì c'è chiede
la verità noi in fondo erano abituati a
internet come una prateria che invitava
la fantasia
ricordate raramente quando le prime e
mail a cui ci siamo iscritti abbiamo
dato il nostro nome e cognome se non per
motivi di lavoro
cioè ci siamo inventati peggio nomi io
mi chiamavo castorino 73 perché mi
piaceva al castore sono del 73 e poi c'è
la farfallina 92 c'erano i nomi più
assurdi di solito era l'animale
preferito è l'anno di nascita perché
internet ma anche nella mente di chi
l'ha idea l'ha pensato doveva essere
qualcosa che liberasse dalle diversità
dalle gerarchie dai confini dovrà essere
il regno della fantasia dev'essere
l'altra realtà la realtà virtuale
rimandava all'idea no del carnevale del
mascheramento dove il paradosso
ma schieramento che si indossa la
maschera possa essere finalmente me
stesso questa splendida foto sono io
otto anni sono un pagliaccio lo sono
tuttora ma allora potendomi per
mascherare da pagliaccio ero finalmente
me stesso le mie figlie quando si
mascherano da regine sono veramente
delle regine più delle regine avere sono
proprio delle regine e trattano tutti da
schiavi
invece arriva facebook e dice no adesso
scusa tu mi dai il nome il cognome è una
tua foto in manca la questura fanno così
non lo dice mai non ho capito bene di
gioco è finito il carnevale non c'è più
tant'è che se vi ricordate i primi
momenti con facebook sono stati eravamo
un po inebetiti o di fronte a questa
nuova come perché se devo portare in sé
stesso un conto che mi posso mascherare
possa avere la possibilità di farlo ma
l'idea che io debba parlare di me
tant'è che abbiamo portato l'unica cosa
che avevamo di noi cioè il nostro
passato che l'ora ciurme di ex di scuola
che ci vengano a trovare anche se erano
anni che forse per qualche motivo nolano
più contattati ritroviamo l'ex bono del
liceo che invece è alimentato orribile
l'ex bruttina che invece era diventata
bellissima aveva messo su famiglia a
berlino e soprattutto cominciamo a fare
una serie di post in punta di piedi in o
in qualche modo con una con un garbo che
oggi sarebbe impensabile ma che era dato
soprattutto da non sapere bene che fare
noi capivamo che facebook era uno
spettacolo potenziale no lo schermo come
palco
noi come attori baste scriviamo qualcosa
una platea potenzialmente di miliardi di
persone
e i like come applausi però mancava
l'innesco qualcosa nei primi posti erano
abbastanza imbarazzanti c'è qualcuno sì
siamo anche tanti penso che mi farò una
bella doccia
ottimo
c'è addirittura un amico che mandava un
solo poco un solo post al giorno alle 8
del mattino
buongiorno queste del 12 luglio 13
luglio 14 luglio e così per settimane
alla fine diventa quasi una performance
artistica solo buongiorno diceva allora
dopo aver viaggiato lungo questo questa
indagine sul mio passato sul passato di
chi già conoscevo che sono abbastanza
annoiato della esco da facebook e mi
metto a cullare la bambina e fare
qualcosa di più importante
poi ho pensato a questa cosa qua ho
detto però se fino a qualche momento
prima che arrivasse questa questa cosa
qua noi ci divertivamo perché c'era
l'idea del carnevale della maschera
perché non provare a innestare la dentro
facebook per non provare a fare un atto
appunto un po creativo che non provare a
sabotarlo questo che mi chiede il nome e
cognome
e allora deciso di indossare una
maschera la maschera di uno scrittore
contemporaneo vivente italiano
bravissimo molto popolare perché
l'abbiamo visto anche in tv abbia messo
nei teatri negli auditorium colto ma
anche carismatico anche anche anche
piacevole fisicamente ovviamente non
scelgo bene alessandro baricco indosso
la maschera midi scrivo a facebook con
la faccia di alessandro baricco col nome
e il cognome di alessandro baricco
era il 2008 dieci anni fa un'epoca sul
digitale come se fosse un secolo nella
vita reale no
oggi noi siamo smaliziati insomma in
qualche modo io sono amico di napoleone
trovi addirittura dio preme i contatti
cioè il cannone del gianicolo cielo come
il canone del colle romano che ogni
giorno a mezzogiorno spara album c'è
tutto per allora nel 2008 eravamo un po
guardate per fare un esempio che
sembrerà un po paradossale lo è però un
po il pubblico francese di fine
ottocento quando per la prima volta
assiste alla sequenza dei fratelli
lumière quelli che inventano il cinema
ma non sapevamo non sapevano cosa fosse
il cinema ancora quel pubblico lì in
quella sala francese e assistono
l'immagine alla sequenza di un treno che
arriva in stazione
inquadratura fissa la gente comincia a
scappare a gridare uscì dalla sala
perché aveva paura che quello da como
tivoli investisse hai fatte le dovute
proporzioni eravamo ingenui non così
però prendemmo alessandro baricco per
vero oggi non solo ce ne fregherebbe
niente insomma forse sentiamo pure
l'abuso perché bastiamo noi siamo
diventati finalmente se noi stessi
abbiamo indossato la maschera nostra
abbiamo bisogno di altre maschere malora
invece alessandro baricco fu sulla
novità fu la battuta che diede l'avvio a
quello spettacolo che attendevamo
insomma in poche ore la bacheca mia di
alessandro baricco fu invasa da migliaia
di richieste d'amicizia
molti erano fan molti erano critici
soprattutto curiosi che si aggrapparono
a quella bacheca e costruire una
comunità a prescindere da bari a bari
era diventato un pretesto
e voi non potete capire la giostra la
fantasia la leggerezza con cui in quei
giorni la gente si dava appuntamento
sotto quella bacata solo per inventare
solo per condividere soprattutto
invenzioni linguistiche perché pur
sempre a una bacheca di uno scrittore
io mi limitavo io baricco mi limitavo a
scrivere dei post molto banali non
scrivevo alessandro e torinese
alessandro uno scrittore
insomma cose che c'è da ragionare
molto intorno ma sotto partivano fiumi
di parole fiume di scambi ricordo
commenti fatti in rima cioè quello che
commentava cercava la rima con il
commento che precedeva oppure invenzioni
linguistiche prese dal lessico delle
opere delle opere liriche perché molti
sapevano che baricco era ghiotto di
opere liriche ed esperto ovviamente non
mancarono gli scettici no la domanda che
mi fece michele ma se veramente
alessandro baricco e io risposi tu sei
veramente michele dice certo che sono
michele io certo il suo alessandro
baricco ma poi dimostrare di essere cioè
questo dialogo surreale folle poteva
andare avanti oppure no ma stava
dimostrarlo sempre una cosa che non
c'era proprio più bisogno di dirsi che
eravamo baricco no
succedeva qualcosa a prescindere da lui
era esplosa la creatività erano sposi
auto riuscivano dappertutto io che ero
autore diciamo così di professione me li
vedevo da zumpano ad ogni parte c'è una
visione invenzioni capaci di battute
fulminanti capaci di giochi linguistici
che non era solite presumibili fino a
due minuti prima vera e propria
rivoluzione in atto se ci pensate
fantasticano era tornato il teatro un
teatro che poteva spalmarsi ovunque in
quei grandi quando finì in questo
esperimento diciamo dura una settimana
ma non è quello decisivo alla fine fini
quando un certo punto sulla bacheca di
alessandro baricco comparve lui umberto
eco con un commento sono umberto eco
come tutti citando un altro scrittore
walter siti
ora la domanda era veramente il senologo
piemontese il grande intellettuale della
scuola di bologna non era più importante
saperlo
umberto eco fu preso come quando si
prende qualcuno durante un ballo e lo si
trascina dentro balliamo umberto eco era
diventato uno dei tanti amici della
bacheca di alessandro baricco poteva
essere un altro folle come me che sarà
nessuna maschera o era veramente eco
poco importava quello che restò in quei
giorni non fu solo a mio vedere qualcosa
che si depositava nella memoria di
quelle ore quello che era esploso in
quella bacheca era qualcosa che negli
anni avvenire l'anno 2008 passati dieci
anni di quelle miliardi di invenzioni
autorali che voi scrivendo ogni giorno
fotografando immaginando producete hanno
modificato trasformato plasmato ogni
contenuto che noi andiamo poi a godere
come spettatori entrano nelle sale degli
autori nella testa degli sceneggiatori
nella capoccia dei dei poeti e dei
fotografi
tutto ciò che voi scrivete depositate su
quella cosetta li muove qualcos'altro in
una lunga catena che cambia
l'immaginario di tutti è il grande corpo
di una cosa potremmo definire autore
collettivo battute come queste
ne escono non so quante al minuto ma poi
ci pensate è mai accaduto prima sono gli
autori che non eletti a scrivere le
battute adesso cioè di uno smartphone
che uno ci dovrebbe preoccupare la mio
ruolo
a me piace come cosa per tornare in un
aneddoto professionale
poche settimane fa con dei colleghi
dovevamo scrivere una scena che
riguardasse i genitori delle madri dei
padri
avevamo raccontare madri e padri allora
in un'altra epoca un avrebbe aperto un
manuale di genitorialità un saggio di
pedagogia che avrebbe studiato non certo
molto un collega tira fuori uno
smartphone giovane tutto qua dentro in
un social perché una sorta di social ma
è un social
forse il più mefistofelico il più
diabolico social se master inventato un
generatore automatico di
cosi che lasciate dei genitori
il soggetto dei genitori che quella cosa
per cui tu puoi passare una settimana a
discutere ore intorno al regalo da fare
a filippo oppure quella cosa per cui il
padre di sarah scrive se facessimo fare
se i nostri bambini facessimo fare un
corso di scacchi solo che il padre di
sarah lo scrive all'una e 7 di notte è
una roba folle chi di voi è padre un
madre sa di cosa sto parlando una cosa
ci puoi perdere la vita oltre che le
sinapsi
però lì dentro è il diario che noi
compiliamo quotidianamente volendo non
volevo raccontando le nostre ansie le
nostre ambizioni e soprattutto cosa
siamo noi come padri e madri allora noi
facendoci largo tra i cuoricini e regali
di filippo siamo riusciti a tirare giù
quello che io considero il perfetto
profilo della madre del padre
contemporaneo e avete scritto voi
abbiamo scritto noi quella cosa lì
pensando di fare altro in realtà abbiamo
solo raccontato noi stessi ecco mi
piacerebbe che stasera non solo ci
lasciassimo con quest'idea che sembra un
po balzana ma io ci credo che siamo
tutti autori ma ci lasciassimo con una
cosa in più c'è il fatto che a
completare questa dimensione out orale
sia la consapevolezza di essere autori
che la consapevolezza di essere autori
per gli altri cioè che quando voi vedete
una cosa bella
la fotografate spesso un tramonto ma
come un gattino ma comunque è una cosa
belva inquadrate la immaginate la
filtrate la commentatela condividete voi
lo fate per gli altri che ciò che vi ha
commosso pensate possa commuovere gli
altri se una cosa vi fa ridere voi la
mettete in forma in forma di battuta e
la condividete perché pensate agli altri
leader e spesso ridono se qualcosa mi
indigna verrà pubblicata in modo che
anche gli altri si indigni ne siano
spinti a discutere magari a convincervi
del contrario
essere autori essere consapevole di
essere autori per gli altri e vorrei
lasciarvi con alcune righe di un testo
di un libro uscito da poco recita così
nei prossimi 100 anni mentre
l'intelligenza artificiale ci porterà
più lontani da noi non ci sarà merce più
preziosa di tutto ciò che farà sentire
umani gli uomini per quanto possa oggi
sembrare assurdo il bisogno più diffuso
sarà quello di salvare un identità della
specie
a quel punto raccoglieremo quello che
avremmo seminato in questi anni e
attenzione la consapevolezza di essere
autori non è solo avere ritrovare un
rapporto se vogliamo più sano
responsabile con i social ma un rapporto
diverso col mondo perché è lì che noi
buttiamo il nostro sguardo per
raccogliere le cose che poi andremo a
raccontare questo testo qua e di un
libro uscito da poco di alessandro
baricco
o forse è mio o forse vostro
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]